you were mentioning you know you had
written for the root at one point would
you consider yourself to have been a
leftist at that point i've never been a
leftist no i've always had what people
would deem traditional views
i'm conversant in sort of and at that
point when i was writing for the root i
would say they were more liberal than
leftists right they've definitely taken
a harder
shift now i'd say over the last seven
years but you had critical thinking
capabilities seems like a smart guy and
so you are just sticking to your
principles and what you think makes the
most sense uh
when we talk about the leftists and the
socialists i don't think
you know critical thought no extends
very far no there are some people i've
met who have been fairly smart and are
just wrong but there's a lot of people
who just i gotta pull up this story
we got a good one
from newsweek.com
socialist magazine current affairs fires
staff for trying to organize workers
co-op
how many times you need to see these
stories to realize that these leftist
institutions that magazines or media
publications they claim to be
progressive or have socialist values
and then the moment someone tries to
unionize which is like a core tenet of
you know labor rights they fire these
people yep you know the funniest thing
about it is is like for me they would
call me right or far right or whatever
and i'm like more power to my staff if
they i don't care or whatever like i
really don't understand why you know the
young turks did it they that story where
like some guy was trying to unionize and
jenkins like screaming at him like slams
papers on the ground and i'm like you
guys are the progressives who advocate
for this yeah so so let me just read a
little bit and then we'll dive in
the founder of the socialist magazine
current affairs has reportedly
effectively fired several staff members
after they tried to organize a workers
co-op former employees claimed in the
letter on wednesday the letter which was
addressed to comrades by several
employees of the of the print and
digital magazine that focuses on topics
from a left-wing perspective said they
had been effectively fired by the
founder nathan j robinson who was also
authored a book why you should be a
socialist
uh is that grifting wow in a tweet
accompanying the letter managing and
amusements editor lita gold wrote i am
grieved to tell you that nathan j robson
has effectively fired me and most of the
current affairs staff because we're
trying to organize into a workers co-op
this isn't a bit i wish it was oh wow
i don't think these you know i guess
what he said was that
you know socialism in in practice is a
lot easier or i'm sorry in theory is a
lot easier than it is in practice so
why would you fire them though
i really don't look i run a company
we've got employees and when these
stories have come up i've always thought
like i don't understand why these people
care so much yeah i mean
as someone who has you know some
experience working in the government
unionization is is a is a you know a
tricky issue because in some respect
yeah you know collective bargaining and
and you know the benefits of being in a
union
but oftentimes it makes
doing work somewhat more difficult which
is why i think
one of the reasons you see a lot of
left-leaning
institutions fight against charter
schools is because
charter schools typically don't have
unionized teachers the teachers unions
don't have as much power over charters
as they do over government schools so
um i mean i i could see how it gets
complicated an employer might feel like
you know if if
their staff unionizes that they are
going to lose some power which they very
well might
but the irony the delicious irony
is that this happens all the time with
the left
i think you've seen it with defund the
police yeah um i'm thinking my mind
always goes to seattle where
the mayor allowed
you know
radicals and and our kids to take over
you know part of her city
and she said you know chop chop chaz is
a summer of love until a member of the
city council marched them to her house
yup then she shut it down like the next
day yeah
you see this all of the time where it's
like
they make rules for for the little
people to follow that they don't want to
follow themselves and i think that is
one of the fundamental flaws and
weaknesses of
that particular line of thinking that
world view is that it's always going to
eat itself you know what i was thinking
i'm just like this guy for the socialist
magazine is probably and i mean this to
the right of me politically right
because as much i think
look i can i can favor certain economic
policies but
i i really do think well put this way
idealistically i'm pretty left
libertarian realistically i'm kind of
like centrist like moderate liberal type
although that's politically homeless at
this point because i don't know what
makes sense but you know when i'm
thinking about a union forming i'm like
yeah i don't care if they come and
they're like hey we want all these
things i'll be like is it possible okay
i don't know why i need all that power
or why i need to be debating people if
like this is what they're looking for
now i can certainly understand when they
bring in external unions and then they
just you know can meddle in the affairs
and all stuff that i get but i think
about like january of the young turks
when he snapped at his employees it's
because they personally want power right
they're authoritarian right their
capitalists pay more power to them right
but they're masquerading as progressives
right i mean same thing going back to
blm
right they
by the end of 2020 patrice cullers had i
think she had a deal with time warner
she had amassed a pretty impressive real
estate portfolio
i mean
the the leaders were living living
pretty high on the hog and it just show
goes to show you that
capitalism in our country as imperfect
as as it is and and really a lot of it's
corporatism but let's for the sake of
argument
capitalism is so powerful in this
country that even marxists can find a
market and make money off yes capitalism
is so powerful that even the socialists
are capitalists yeah yeah yeah so yeah
you you saw that so for all the talk and
whether it's them or colin kaepernick i
mean
these are some well-heeled
revolutionaries that's for sure
it's true
it's like a revolution in the revolution
they decided you know we could just make
money doing this yeah it's like the
ibram candy thing you mentioned yeah
he's not actually going to come out and
be like hey this id thing is wrong no i
mean there there's a great opportunity
for him to like
think about this if he was principled so
maybe he will do it i don't think he
will maybe he will i don't could you
imagine he has an opportunity right now
to come out and say i told you this i
told you the state would do this de
blasio is racist and he's doing it right
now and in fact people would probably be
like debasio is racist we don't like him
and and and that's why i part of the
reason i wrote the article because i i
would be truly
um
curious to see whether he would take
such a principal position or any of his
acolytes not just him right he may not
do it but to see anyone who believes in
his version of quote-unquote anti-racism
i would love to see them actually take
that principle step and say
we said that any policy that has
disproportionate impacts on different
ethnic groups is racist this one has it
we're calling it racist and we stand by
it imagine getting to stand up at a
press conference and say we warned you
yeah we begged you the government would
do this
and it is a democrat who did it to our
in our faces you'd you'd you'd have just
like look look at look at we're right
yeah but they don't want to do it
because then they're actually going up
against their political agenda right and
and i mean talk about strange bedfellows
if ibram kennedy ends up being the
patron saint of the rights
anti-vaccine mandate push
right if if he is on a stage with
ted cruz
we're both against vaccine mandates we
may be against them for different
reasons yeah i mean i think everybody
would freak out at that point see that's
principle right right so i you know i
i'll take it to um
joe biden he gave that speech on
afghanistan and a lot of conservatives
are just saying it was bad it was awful
then you had
clarissa ward cnn reporter on the ground
in afghanistan she's wearing the burqa
and she said
they're chanting death to america
but they're also seemingly friendly it's
bizarre and what happened a lot of
conservatives cut out the it's bizarre
part yeah and only showed the first part
it's very clear when you when you add
that it's bizarre she was contrasting
what they were saying and doing us do
different things right granted i do
think her words were you know poorly
poorly chosen but in terms of biden
speech cassandra fairbanks a good friend
of mine said she actually thought it was
a good speech because he said things
that needed to be said like we shouldn't
be you know passing the buck on this war
we shouldn't be sending our you know
kids to go fight this
but when you're speaking on principle
you will often find that the people who
follow you get mad because they might be
speaking on tribe for tribal reasons so
you know following someone like mike
cernovich he's he's criticized trump a
lot and and the trump supporters get mad
at him like oh what happened to you and
he's like i'm being honest i'm telling
you exactly how i feel as i've always
done
so if if candy and these other critical
race theorists were actually functioning
on principle they'd have come out in two
seconds and been like no way no no no no
no absolutely absolutely and i mean i
know
they're all different types of policy
areas you know social domestic economic
political
that a person like candy could apply you
know his principles
um
if black lives matter was really an
honest slogan and an organized
organization they would plant themselves
in front of every planned parenthood in
the black community which planned
parenthood typically target communities
of color
and
um the same people who will say we're
against liquor stores and the people
pushing cigarettes in low-income black
communities for some reason they don't
take that same approach when it comes to
uh planned parenthood but
um
candy wouldn't do that because in new
york city and a lot of people don't know
this
about half of
all
um
of black women's pregnancies end in
abortion in new york city so half of all
black babies are aborted in new york
city
if you want to talk about something
that's systemic there it is but again
his his anti-racism is only useful to
their position to the extent that it
furthers their political goals so
certain things they'll say you know what
we'd rather talk about these 19 police
shootings a year then talk about
you know street crime or abortion or the
state of urban education you know those
are those are different issues for a
different day
so i just looked it up on live action or
is it live action live
action
and they said that uh black women
account for 38 of all u.s abortions
that sounds really creepy it's true
that's true
that's true and so so that's why
for me i always question i i
i think like how
uh how do i put this
i mean someone really has to be doing a
number on you for you to think
that
it makes sense to give 90 of your
political support to a party
whose
central policy or one of them i'd
probably say the top three
is to keep your population at exactly 13
that that's what i was thinking when you
start talking about i'm like
planned parenthood's been around for a
long long time what are you doing 100
years something yeah and they and they
uh i was looking at a map from planned
parenthood and they do have a bunch of
minority area centers
and i'm thinking like i wonder what the
pers the population size would have been
for the black and hispanic community if
planned parenthood wasn't doing that
yeah
and considering 38 percent of all
abortions that's that's an extremely
disproportionate number absolutely
absolutely and i mean
again that they
the the democrats talk a good game about
race
but you know where their where their uh
policy priorities lie because every time
a supreme court nominee comes up they
don't ask them their views on brown
versus board of ed they ask them their
videos on roe versus wade so that is one
of their central policies and for
whatever reason
um you know black leaders don't question
it and so i always ask people
i'd say do you think the the position of
most black americans would be the same
on abortion if it was republicans who
were pushing it
if if ted cruz was the one saying no we
need more abortion clinics in houston
and dallas
do you really think that black voters
will respond the same and i've yet to
get a good answer to that but that's one
of those things where um for me when i
write part of what i'm trying to do is
recapture some of the territory that the
left has taken um while while some of
the leaders in my community quote
unquote have been asleep at the wheel
that's a strategy for conservatives i
guess yeah just just come out and be
like you know what we thought about it
yeah they're right keep doing it and
then have people like wait but they're
racists i mean and all i said like no no
that's okay we agree that's the age-old
thing right if you want if you want
teenagers to stop doing something just
get their parents to do it and say hey
look we're getting tattoos all over our
face we're smoking you know six packs
we're just like you know
and this oh i don't want to be like my
parents
so
you know i i have a question um
they say that uh what what's saying that
the the path to the electorate the black
community is through the church or
something that affects you you've heard
something like that
i i have um
i think that may be an outdated
way of thinking particularly for younger
generations right right right now people
let's say
you know black voters over 65 who are
still heavily church going i could see
that so i mean you saw that in
the democratic primary where biden
captured south carolina you know on the
strength of a lot of older black female
voters many of whom were church going
the younger demographic that is a lot
less the case
so you can see that shift
in the civil rights movement from
a faith-based movement into a more sort
of secular secular humanist
uh movement blm has nothing to do and
not marxist right and now outright
marxist um so i think for younger
generations that's less the case i think
in many respects
the church has
a lot less influence in the black
community than it used to
i would actually take a more
controversial position on why that is
because
for a lot of people
they think of the black church as
primarily a service provision
organization it's basically the naacp
but with a sort of uh you know a
spiritual twist to it um i would argue
that the black church has lost a lot of
its significance because it stopped
preaching the gospel
and it's losing people because
as
more and more black folk got you know
became more economically
uh independent and more upwardly mobile
the need for a service provision
organization went away and the church's
relevance has waned a lot since you know
dr king's age but i'm sure for a lot of
democratic pollsters they still think
that the church is the way to go
but in
50 years
i would be curious to see you know what
what that looks like is that good or bad
um which part
the the loss of influence from the
church oh it's terrible i think i think
in general
the loss of um the decline in religious
affiliation
is is bad for the country and i say it
this way and i realize people have all
different types of you know
um
political views and theological views
and i respect that um i do think that
there's a place in the public square
for
uh religious people
um
i think that
this last
couple of years has shown that
there's an innate
need in humanity to worship something
for a lot of us politics has filled that
void yeah that religion used to to to
fill and and that's why you see
you know the the sort of political
partisanship almost take on a religious
feel
now i i would sort of make the argument
tongue-in-cheek that for the right
that looks a little bit more catholics
mossy so where you have a figure like
trump who almost functions as a pope the
things that he says to some of his
supporters
that he says from his office you know
ex-cathedra are almost like the gospel
to them
and on the left
i would liken that more to a more
protestant small p type of religion
because there's always something to
protest there's always it's
environmentalism it's uh racism sexism
homophobia transphobia xenophobia
and
that desire to find something to give my
life some meaning
um
you see that playing out in our in our
you know day-to-day discourse on
politics and in in every other area so i
think
again as a christian i i would obviously
i am i want to advance a biblical
christian worldview
um i realize other people have different
views but i think part of what makes
america america is to have that public
square
um and i think protecting that you know
you know i i think of frederick douglass
he talked about the three boxes of
liberty
he talked about
um
the jury box
the ballot box and the cartridge box was
that frederick douglass yeah i would add
a fourth one the soapbox oh right and i
think having an uh a robust first
amendment where people can come
and debate and discuss issues whether
they have the same worldview the same
political ideology or not that's
something that we need to to have a
healthy functioning republic was that
frederick douglass said that cartridge i
don't know if that cartridges what oh
they definitely had cartridges back in
the 1900s yeah
three boxes of liberty i'm not sure if
he was the first person to say it but
he's probably the most famous person to
say talked about the three boxes of
liberty right on yeah well it's a good
quote either way
man it just makes me
i think uh
you know we we
have a shared moral framework whatever
this faction might end up being uh i'm
not a christian i grew up catholic
briefly i do believe in god but um i
have my own like weird
spirituality and worldview or whatever
but i but i do have a moral framework
that is built upon the traditions of you
know judeo-christian faith
and i i obviously recognize that and i
think a lot of people in america do and
one of the examples i often use is that
bill is bill maher bill mark very
clearly holds values that are rooted in
a judeo-christian moral framework
notably the right of the innocent to be
uh you're innocent until proven guilty
right which is blackstone's fourth
rooted in blackstone's formulation which
is rooted in the story of sodom and
gomorrah if there's but one righteous
person and i will not destroy the city
but the woke don't have that moral
framework no they have a lack of a moral
framework and so i was i've been
thinking about this for a while you know
about why it is that they were so
diametrically opposed and what the
factions really are and i'm like well
they don't have a moral framework at all
yesterday they can say x is good
tomorrow they'll say x is bad right you
know if enough people say that x is bad
right so there's no there's no grounded
moral framework it's literally just what
the group says is so
whereas for me i'm like i don't care
what the group says i know my moral
framework yeah yeah so i think a lot of
what a lot of our political debates are
sort of um
geometric debates right it's about
drawing lines the question is where is
the line going to be drawn and by what
standard so
the left definitely is religious as i
said it's just that religion may be a
religion of self
it may be you know a religion of
scientism or safetyism
but
the the way that the woke
um sort of frame their arguments
oftentimes in a religious you know with
religious language slavery and racism as
original sin
right um
talking about issues like reparations as
it relates to paying off a debt which
again
draws on on some you know
christian language in terms of
uh what believers believe that christ
did on the cross right to pay a debt for
sinners
the problem with the wokes religion
is that its god is never fully and
finally satisfied so the christian
believes that christ paid
our sin debt on the cross with his death
burial and resurrection but for the left
its god is never propitiated there's
there's no forgiveness no forgiveness
so they they believe in sin the same way
that i do right microaggressions that's
that's what it is it's you know small
sins i mispronounce your name i i
thought you were the wrong hispanic guy
in the office oh and now i have to get
you know smacked on the hand by hr so so
they believe in some of the same
principles in terms of of sin and
offense and uh atonement is just as i
said their god is never satisfied and i
think you see
that that saga that um that
cosmic saga is playing out in our
politics on a day-to-day basis it'll be
interesting in 10 years when these when
these kids either you know i hear a lot
of stories that young kids are anti-woke
because they're telling their their
teachers the teachers like who wants to
be like their teacher yeah the teacher
comes out the teacher is a loser you
know
the kids don't view the teachers as cool
yeah yeah i mean i think i mean there's
always i learned this you know taking
engineering like there's always
you know you swing a pendulum one way it
eventually is gonna it's gonna swing
back
um i'd be curious to see what that looks
like you know whether kids take on a
certain anti-authoritarian strain
sometimes it's hard to see that because
when i see kids who are four or five
years old when as soon as they get out
of the car the first thing they're doing
is
reaching for their mask even my
two-year-old now he's three at the time
he was two
we were going we would you know go
somewhere and he said dad where's my
mask and i'm like you don't need a mask
we're outside you're in the park just go
and play
but a lot of our kids are being
conditioned
in the same way that adults are and i
hope
what we don't end up seeing is an even
larger increase in
anxiety and depression
and neuroticism and all the other things
that we've been seeing play out for you
know the better part of the last 20
years
yeah man well we can be optimistic um to
the best of our abilities for sure i'm
i'm i teeter back and forth sometimes
depending on what's going on you know
there's optimism in you know we already
shouted at michael mouse shut him up
again he's very optimistic he says these
people are so dumb how could you
possibly be pessimistic and i'm like
it's not a bad point you know but but
zombies are dumb and a lot of zombies
can overrun a city you know so that's
true
my hope is that
eventually people's eyes will open
so whether it's foreign policy in
afghanistan whether it's
people who were saying defund the police
last year
saying refund the police this year
all of these issues the socialist who's
who fires all the employees who want to
unionize that's so good
what i'm hoping is that people see that
the people that we think are elites and
the smartest people in our society have
no idea what they're doing and honestly
in many respects like we were talking
about homeschooling
nobody has done more to advocate and
advance the cause of school choice and
homeschooling than the teachers unions
they have done a way better job of
promoting homeschooling than any gop
politician ever could so when you see
how
how not just corrupt but incompetent
the leadership classes
it'll make people say you know what why
should i listen to these people they
have no idea what they're talking about
about anything so yeah right on thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you